[Music]
today is all about celebrities we're
gonna talk about who the hottest
celebrities are we're gonna do an
impressions face-off but first watch
this so this video comes to us from Gaga
and doing things it's got three thousand
four three fifty four retweets and it's
a supercut of lady gaga over and over
again saying the same thing no there can
be a hundred people hundred people 100
people in the room I probably said this
earlier but there can be a hundred
people or a thousand people in the room
and nine thousand or nine and nine
hundred ninety nine don't believe in you
and and one does and I would not be here
without you
it's crazy actually did the same
compilation with Ryan stand up I
actually want to do it on Shark Tank I
want to go there and I'd be like look
you I will give you 30% of all the money
I make over the rest of my life and you
just please pay for my wedding
just take it I'm not gonna make much do
you guys find this now Lady Gaga's more
authentic lecithin dig now that you've
been saying the same thing and every as
authentic as I thought well she changes
her looks so much but can't change one
word you're gonna say a different thing
every time you're interviewed that's
exhausting like I like I have to say it
everything every time on this show and
that's like really tiring so I like to
say the same
if marble the question is now the world
wouldn't have answered that she's
definitely a close are we doing this for
a fact
I mean that I didn't believe in clothes
I didn't think they got Gucci Mane a
tree grows but I know they got Lady gaga
do you do you think that every different
time she changed your look it's just
actually a different Gaga like robots
across the world he just fired him off
like I am it so we looked up IMDB star
meter to find out where Bradley Cooper
and Lady gaga
are currently on the hottest stars list
at the top baby so I'm gonna run you
through who are currently the top five
trending celebrities number one we got
Naomi Scott number two Tom Hardy three
Meena Masood Lady gaga five Scott Wilson
Cooper any surprises there yes yeah but
I can't remember their name so Marty
makes it Sir Walter Isaacson Scott
Wilson Baio he was in The Walking Dead
he recently died Warren Goodwin Ryan
what about Tom Hardy you saw did you see
venom I saw I haven't seen venom but I
imagine he still has the thing where you
can't understand anything he's saying
[Laughter]
save it we've got an impression faceoff
coming up who do you think should be in
the top five
Zac Efron obviously he's coming out with
that movie about the serial killer
what's what's the guy McGee Dom it know
the guy who's hot who killed all his
washboard stomach killer Dahmer was it
different with you it's like really good
I don't know what carbs killer no it's
some serial killers and compare their
hotness no it was the hot serial killer
why do you think they cast up
I was gonna kill me I would have sex
with him knowing he was gonna kill me
Hannibal Lecter
that's who you Ted Bundy women willingly
got murdered what'd she say we've
decided Ted Bundy hottest celebrity now
and forever no it is officially time for
the impressions face-off Ryan and Jordan
are gonna go head-to-head and they're
gonna give us their best impression of
three people now they have been given 24
hours to prepare for these impressions
including sleep all right so your judges
really good impression I think you're
gonna be so good
are Chris and Hannah okay ready around
wildly objectively easy the first round
this is a trending impression Gillian
put it up this is Bradley Cooper from a
star is born we didn't have a coin toss
we had one in my head Jordan you won so
you get to decide first or second for
this first round for this first round
yes I'll go first for the first okay
you're Bradley Cooper hey I haven't seen
the movie yet and I'm pretty sure I just
made this movie to grow my hair out and
you know if 14 million people believe
and don't believe in you but like one
does there's 313 million nine hundred
ninety nine thousand look the coupe's on
your side okay so judges what do we
think listen you just make the decision
that you feel most comfortable with I
will say that if you don't give me a
point right now then I will not have a
point for the rest of the impressions
yeah and I get a lyric from shallow the
song I just
[Music]
[Laughter]
change
he said I'm hard change
[Laughter]
I think the powder and it's important to
powder yourself okay I really want to
give you $20 if you I'm gonna have to
get to Jordan pretty upsetting but I
don't think I'm the kind of guy to start
screaming all right now it's time for a
character impression Jillian put up that
picture it is from bang from Batman
sounds like this but I'll tell you this
every damn day people of Comedy Central
there was a travesty because my Bradley
Cooper was a little bit better than this
current voice I don't agree with the
judges I feel like a French figure
skater the skater are the French times
it was many years ago but so is bangs
thank you
[Music]
seeing this go so it sorta sounds like a
circus performer it's someone who I
think it's so smart that Jordan chose to
do the actual thing yeah okay the last
one is a classic impression this is
Julian put it up George Takei all right
I was actually worried about doing this
impression because Ryan does such a good
judge two K but now that I'm doing it I
actually feel pretty confident Oh
commander Sulu's and I Star Trek name
it's also important to remember that the
atrocities against the Japanese - I grew
up in an internment camp I give a very
impassioned hour-long speech and
different talks around the metropolitan
area to discuss these things but it's
important in these times to respect the
whole people now I understand what they
can swipe - who are we gonna go - Ryan
this time
I'm gonna this is from fats layer one
one second please Allah swears nature
aggressive name this is from the from
yesterday when he we had to got with the
Doritos with the pig he's that bro hear
me out
Dorito flavored bacon thanks for that
shut up we're gonna do something else
right now
[Music]
sure the rock is about two men escaping
Alcatraz but isn't it also about how
rewarding it is to spend time with older
people
I'm not doing George Bush man I'm doing
Jackson Hole Mississippi I play guitar
hey hey hey hey I just want to take
another look at any that's why I
followed you in the bathroom mama be
Gaga gaga take another look at us and
make sure to LIKE comment subscribe and
check us out on Twitter on our show
extra damn day
[Music]